she wanted me to to head him back but I
chose not to Prince Harry shares more
details about the alleged altercation
with his brother Prince William
Harry's detailing of the of the physical
fight between him and William was was
shocking to read and we we know that the
brothers
um had fallen out that they were not on
talking terms but to discover that
actually things have gotten so bad that
they became physical it is quite
shocking in a new interview with itv's
Tom bradby Harry opens up about the
alleged fight detailed in his tell-all
Memoir spare out January 10th and the
Duke of Sussex reveals why he didn't
fight back William and I used to fight
all the time we were kids what was
different here was this level of
frustration I saw this Red Mist in him I
can pretty much guarantee today that if
I wasn't doing therapy sessions like I
was and being able to process that anger
and frustration that I would have fought
back 100 percent
um but I didn't because I was in a more
comfortable place with my own anger
in the book Harry claims William
physically attacked him after the two
got into an argument over Harry's wife
Meghan Markle in an excerpt from the
book obtained by the guardian Harry
describes the alleged confrontation at
his London home in 2019 claiming his
brother called Megan difficult rude and
abrasive and says things quickly turned
into a shouting match a similar scene to
the one Harry detailed in his recent
Netflix docu-series Harry and Megan it
was terrifying to have my brother Scream
and Shout out to me and my father say
things that simply went true Harry says
the argument escalated with William
shoving him to the floor she wanted me
to to head him back but I chose not to
Harry talks about a Red Mist coming over
his Rubber and in that moment this is
the anger bubbling up in William clearly
these brothers are just not on the same
page they simply cannot understand one
another so much of the relationship
between me and William the way it played
out was because of the distorted
narrative that was being pushed through
the British press but despite all that
Harry says he still has hope they can
reconcile 100 percent
I genuinely believe that and I hope that
reconciliation between my family and us
will have a ripple effect across the
entire world he speaks about wanting to
reconcile with his family he talks about
the door being open but I think the
feeling is that actually he's made sure
that door has been firmly slammed shut
the idea of any reconciliation seems
almost Unthinkable given what he has
said given the very personal nature of
these attacks because that's what they
are they are verbal attacks on members
of the royal family and not just any
member of the royal family his father
his brother his mother-in-law his
sister-in-law no one is really spared in
spare
[Music]
foreign